hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to with the addition of
markiplier two asses and angels is going
to be a fun time because I'm very eager
to get back into it dirt
have you seen dirt a pile of dirt kinda
looks like dirt let's be careful around
here jack screw that come on move it I
need to get back into my Jack xyn
because I'm not nearly uh wait now where
am I going
wait do you hear something oh no I got a
run with ah I'm dead oh I'm such an
idiot
ah if we got that I could run it it's
better day I didn't played this game in
a while and shut up it's not me it's you
it's used me I don't know I don't know
what I'm saying anymore
screw that come on move it I think it
was writer than he knew wait do you hear
something also why are there boulders in
the spirit world and why all this is bad
this bad is bad ah you didn't tell me
that was gonna be some actual combat in
this game or not combat but you know I
would actually have to use my brain for
something other than reading here we go
again I did not know I thought I was
done I didn't know that they the rocks
were smart enough to jump over gaps how
do we go game face on game mode engage
ready to go go oh no no no no no no ah
gonna be hard god damn it I'm such a
tool okay it's time for real this time
real mode has been engaged someone keep
a running counter in the comments below
of how many times I've failed because I
lose feeling we're not done just yet
yeah here we go here we go off to a
blazing start no fool ups no foul-ups no
fool ups yes I did it I did it now what
happens if I go back because they tried
to uh oh it's like a puzzle it's like a
puzzle a puzzle okay so what are these
things so if I save again I should be
good to go and then I'll be able to go
through go up go nowhere go nowhere oh
come on I saw a shiny in the other area
I can't go back can I
damnit damnit I saw shiny in the last
video bye I thought I would be able to
get do it another way they keep putting
shinies where they know that I can't get
them and then they put them
tantalizingly close the right ways fruit
is tunnel mark man space Australia all
over again for Jack oh where am I we're
getting closer and closer mark let's
just hope it's not getting more and more
deadly for me
I've died like 10 times he doesn't look
happy well he's a pile of bone so that
would probably explain that predicament
I don't know it's more terrifying the
skull were boring ruins they're not
boring I wish I was a Narconon
archaeologist this rock is a
delightfully brown orange color thank
you shall I jump down there no no okay
I'll save that for later thank you very
much don't even speak mark hey Jack you
don't want to hear about the rocks
these rock here stop looking at the
rocks mark oh no how about no ah look at
that
yep I'm just yep I shut up and about two
rocks mark I used to have a better
jacket pressure than that
I can't wait to not look at this thing
Hey look a bed that's probably useful
let me go see what these rooms are over
here that looks like the hole that tiny
box Tim jumped out of what an astounding
incredible Rock I can't understand any
you need markings it's like the wall is
about crack good that's exactly what I
would say in that situation what that
was this ancient symbols mark it's sort
of a symbol language around here you
know what it says well I've been
brushing up on it I could give it a try
yes the man with meat um something about
a good time happy endings Jack that's a
bit perverted I can't really understand
most of it mark that's fine I don't
think anyone out there wanted to know
what that was about that story was
totally weird and strange and I have no
idea what it meant so let's just go with
that basic assumption and move out of
their lives
No Bob killed Wade Bob really did it
Wade you come down to join us Wade did
the Angels send you here - uh not
exactly
wha he died what how Bob Bob killed me
that's [ __ ] Bob huh he seemed
reluctant to kill me you wouldn't have
it if it wasn't for the angel calm down
mark we got to get out of here first
then we get to Bob I'm going to kill him
all in due time mark nothing we can do
about it now
way join the party oh good Wade's with
us now I seriously can't think of
anything to say what about you Wade uh
this rock uh rocks shut up Wade Thank
You Wade it's good have been you wait if
that had bed hadn't been there wait I
said we're in the spirit world well I
bet if anyone was reading with that what
that was saying they get pretty upset
with how much I would speak about
nothing right let's just keep going mark
all right these pillars sort of creep me
out everyone liking the voices so far
I'm really putting a lot of work into
these ones here they're definitely high
quality high caliber ah a rock some
familiar territory Jack are there
monsters around here oh it's nothing to
worry about mark says you you're already
dead see okay Jack why is there a bed in
the middle of a cave see that opening up
there mark yes that's where we inhale
through do you remember what you landed
on when you got here bunches of long
grass
yes when you fall down into the spirit
world it's made sure that you land on
something soft wait so I get grass and
Wade gets a bed I landed on a bunch of
poison ivy consider yourself lucky we
got eat cheese all over my lucky charms
okay moving on Jack are there monsters
around here oh no I already said that
okay
nope I mean we're all dead except maybe
me I better grab those mushrooms before
the Ames who comes after me yeah Bob you
better do Oh lag Oh lag is that just
mirrors is there legitimately lagging
this area is that just me
oh there's laggy laggy laggy leggy hey
stuttering bye
this isn't the 60 frames per second that
everyone was hoping for okay we're gonna
make it why are there monsters in these
Wimbley woods bleh oh god damn it why is
it lagging there I've never ever ever
seen an RPG game lag so I guess yeah oh
boy alright let's just do this so we get
through this I'm just gonna do it to it
ahsha ahsha ahsha ahsha
Shan Shan Tori shabadoo Oh Chabot ingo
Lilly Lilly
oh yeah the last one yay Bob survived
whoo darn it I really have to go to the
toilet okay Bob you do that how about
saving with some radical soda first Bob
you're sounding a lot like me did you
catch the horrible markiplier disease
okay oh yes I need something to read oh
all right I didn't get to explore
anything else I got Bob straight to the
point
hey wait a minute this book is on
ancient monsters just because it is and
don't ask why and here's a fake angel
let's see in order to defeat with the
one cast in an angel skin you must
obtain power beyond recognition that's
it that's far too vague I don't even
know what it means but what the hell man
this guy went all out on this one
hijack okay I am assuming this is us
exploring the cave and then finding a
way out
holy carpets cold not really mark
wayde's we can't feel the cold
yeah wait I'm freezing my balls off
maybe I can dance to warm up I'm dancing
right on Jack right on his face okay oh
yeah feel the bird now to twerk pass it
up mark I've had enough my face is taken
enough oh man yes I'm gonna explore
everything I've learned my lessons from
numerous games dumped rump dump Trump
lump pump rob slump whomp
is that even a word Wade I don't know
come on mark head head were Klaus
are we close great rock what is the deal
with you and rocks mark I don't know
don't ask me
looks like an ancient pillar why does
everything have to be ancient because
it's a spirit world people have been
dying for a while a snow-covered broken
pillar excuse me wait who's the main
character here tree it's great see
nature so full a tree blue just like
your mom just like your bob last night
Oh sick burn okay I guess it's enough
it's well established by now that I like
rocks okay hello wait what why is there
snowman here why is there a pile of
blood he's got a cute go no why is there
a pile of blood still gonna go to that
one this looks fresh hmm yep tastes
fresh too
I'm weird wait what why Oh ever did he's
not cute he's gonna follow us I'm not
gonna be able to explore all the rocks
logs stop talking to the trees afraid
this will be the last time I see you
rock even though we only just met
I love you
well what the heck on rounds are you
crazy I don't want to even go near that
thing whatever it is well it's most
likely a dragon a dragon come on let's
go
no dragon your heels a key Jack are you
sure that's you I'm getting sick of all
these damn rocks you know you can create
a dam out of rocks uh-huh oh let's go oh
my god is the epic showdown between Jack
me Wade and the dragon
that's a scary face that I'm putting on
there what inception button appropriate
for this situation what the hell yeah
what the hell what's going on I'm sorry
mark some people can't take it
what do you mean being down here gets T
I'm on let's either go crazier this
goofy bears what do you mean wait on the
off chance that you might go completely
bonkers and speared my kitchen corrupted
that makes no sense but go on please
please please her man let's just say
yeah mess can handle the heat so he left
the kitchen on the plus side he can now
touch things like me goddamn I gotta do
something about this before it gets a
mark Lizzie your right has hard hell not
gonna save yamimash no I do blob blob
what's a B why why was why would that
save young man why why what why
with but stabbing on the mass save him
all right I bet if I can stab him in the
butt he'll have to come back to his
senses he'll remember me
don't take that's how it works mark Yami
quick turnarounds to stab you in the
butt Debbie please Yami no I am lay dead
I'm dead I'm dead arenot dead gonzo
somehow that didn't work I don't know
why but it kind of didn't okay this is
the silliest thing I've ever done on my
life like this game is bar none the
silliness Silius and I love it I really
hope that I don't have to go back and
like watch all this like go through and
read oh is it gonna punish me for not
reading every single every single thing
cuz I really hope it does because I
don't want to all right whatever
here we go I got the saves I'm saving on
different spots every time so let's just
run for the portal and we've bored yeah
oh maybe I look alike find an item or
something before I met him
maybe I got a garage saved if corrupted
sue I'll have to go back and do it all
again and I might have to do all that in
the third episode this is like a long
game
- oh yeah
are you feeling today yeah yamimash the
ju-young what's going on we already read
all this blah blah blah yeah I don't
want to accidentally hit the thing okay
and run from the border
I'm so sorry I couldn't get to you wait
a minute I had wings
why am i [ __ ] yeah that's what I said
no so those why said now we need to get
out of here ah damn it
well this is apparently happening now oh
okay that's it then traitor
oh no I was trying to help them you will
die oh I was trying to help Bob turn
around in those boxes what am I looking
for quick everyone hold the angel down
hey hey jump on her jump on her face
that's fine horse ass get the wharf - I
can't hold her for much longer
yeah the action is really like heart
pounding right there all the animation
that's happening just keep I refuse
don't let the day a win get all you got
Boyd okay I'm ready
God can't I kill me I am
oh hi I am you're full of heroin baby oh
how do I do Bob and worth it you're a
fuller hair ruined baby damn we we did
it now mark I know you must be wondering
what had the hell I was doing
oh come on everyone you can explain
later let's just grab some beer and
relax
only someone who thinks all Irishmen
drink beer would say something like that
how about a cream soda or some cherry
coke uh okay I just I would just wish we
could have saved yamimash you know mark
I did see something sparkly when you
first entered the spirit world but it
was probably nothing I'm sure you're
right no I saw it too you got the
powerful but unaware any I saw it too I
just didn't know Jesuit I'm going back
screw it there's enough time I'm going
back I'm doing it again let me do it
again
god this it saw so many different
endings man do I have enough time I have
enough time I do I have enough time I
probably have enough time okay where was
a big gap damn it I'm go for I got save
you I'll be back
I gotta save you I'll be nice play by
dumb excuse me I hit myself overdose
save you up yes oh I see right here
there are vines oh I can climb up here
with my pretty little kitty claws that's
why I was a kitty Oh
amazing at the rock nice architecture
yay you a sparkler doodad obtained a
mystical rod through your mystical bit
the rock mark can we go now hila dirt
hasn't been any TLC in years by the look
of it that's tender loving care actually
mark I just Paula shot the other day oh
really
of course not can we freaking go I want
to live again alright Jack yes yeah yeah
grumpy Gus judges they're the only
person that I know who actually stops to
look at rocks maybe I don't need this
topic look at rocks maybe maybe I don't
oh oh this is a different path hi there
mark damn I'm not even gonna ask how you
got down here but the upper vision for
me
mark whoa Oh what the hell well this
place got decrepit fast I thought this
was my home but ah well crap I ain't
going back that way I thought it was
gonna roll towards me
uh okay what the hell did it mean
whoa I think I know ah it means you'll
be home real soon shall I start rolling
shall we find something decrepit do I
change my name to Sally mix agate it's
you'll find out eventually just give it
time okay then I guess I'll save this
new adventure that we're taking wait
what wait where's my radical sign
no that here marked okay but there's a
lot of stuff to explore too bush it's
another bush I love my bushes
don't put your mind in the gutter
everybody amazing incredible thing it's
cracking the ground tree over dere
doodads what heads what's with all this
blood somebody didn't have fun here what
why why so much blood an incredible Loch
Rock hey Jack
yes mark this rock is solid boulder good
god mark that was terrible we got what
about the holes in the ground ten thing
about the holes in the ground oh my god
zip it a time mark I hope you do great
okay thanks okay all right I'll be right
back oh I can't wait a minute II blew
oh okay I'm dumbing down the hole now
okay well alright then you sassy [ __ ]
you why don't you just okay
alright uh what else could happen when I
just jump down a random ass hole in the
ground what about this other random ass
hole in the ground I'm not going down
there why not why not me why not why
don't you go down huh where'd you get in
huh oh god I gotta do this goodbye come
on [ __ ] duhkha [ __ ] god damn it okay
then we gotta gotta gotta gotta got it
that took a while yeah I'd be lifted
with the bathroom tell you one more
thing I'm gonna explode it's time
everybody I got the mystical rod and I'm
with yamimash now and I will be able to
cure him of his plight blah blah blah
we've already read through all of this
you're meemers me boom give I gotta do
something a portal not gonna do that
I got a mystical rod let's see if this
sells anything huh
take this magical stick that I found on
the wall it worked
Yami walk don't worry everyone they're
just hugging there Blake 10 feet apart
doesn't that mean I can't write doesn't
mean I can't write some argue about fat
action out who is come on everyone let's
get to the portal
all right Shree I know I tried your help
that you will die your death will be
long and horrific wait so he was that's
what I say bar he didn't wanted to be in
the Bible with you by boobity boobity
bomb over table meeting me this morning
wait what now best we put a great I'm
gonna kill you god dammit you son of a
[ __ ] Wow
yikes mark that was a little overkill
well it had to be done at some point are
we gonna have another party it's going
to be a party now there is I meet this
morning and that's why that worked I
guess what we meet again mark Oh still
sexy Daniel oh you're so sexy
just kidding have fun I'm not kidding
it's good to be live Marky pants
you said it Irish guy whatever you're
not forget I'm so drunk
whatever any Doritos mark wait is that
all you care about I care about um I
said Doritos you gay Marguerite oh okay
seems to be impossible to step over the
rose big I mean everything to be live
out blah blah blah that music be banging
yo me to save all you [ __ ] that ran
away and didn't save me
I can't save is it thanks for saving its
mark I was trying to help but it never
really got anywhere it's all good Bob
it's all good glad to see that the cat
suit came in handy thanks huh
why is my facebook save me well you've
been dead for a while yeah I'm imagine
you kind of got turned into a dragon so
I don't know what to tell you all right
so I guess I guess I got to go say hi to
time done by sin mark wonderful job
thanks
I was surprised dub a division took
place oh yeah
that was meant to be a thing that
happened whoops oh well all right then
sniffs smells good
water fan we think I'm pansy okay
I guess that's it we just dance we dance
the night away
would you like to exit no is it it is
that it oh I guess it's just a party and
that's it
uh I guess I guess I just go yeah I
guess you got the all-hail Marga
blinding eye but she's the true ending
yeah I did it I did the thing and I did
it good - yeah I'm very proud of myself
I don't know what other ending that
could have possibly been I guess if I
didn't eat meat at the end of that in
the beginning of the game I guess but
then again what kind of me wouldn't need
eat it would be on posture which was in
another pan game that will probably mean
the annotation over there so thank you
everybody so much for watching remember
keep on dancing for the rest of your
life be happy love life you guys are
awesome thanks again everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
oh okay
spooky spooky does real-time not that it
fool the team okay bye